اهلا بكم مشاهدينا مستمرين مستمرون معكم
في تغطيه الدائره في السودان بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع وتشير الانباء الوارده
من الخرطوم في ثالث ايام الاشتباكات الى
ان انقطاع التيار الكهربائي يمنع
المستشفيات من استقبال المصابين علما بان
نقابه اطباء السودان اشارت على سقوط عدد
كبير من الجرحى واكد بيان للجيش السوداني
ان الوضع في الخرطوم يشهد اشتباكات محدوده
حول القياده العامه ووسط العاصمه واكد
الجيش انه يسيطر تماما على جميع مقرات
القياده العامه في الاثناء قال المبعوث
الامامي الى السودان قال ان الجيش والدعم
السريع لم يلتزم بالهدنه الانسانيه الا
جزئيا وفيما تتصاعد وتيره الاشتباكات دعت
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا الى وقف فوري
لاطلاق النار في السودان وعوده العسكريين
الى ثكناتهم
وكان قد نفى مصدر في الجيش السوداني
للعربيه ما تم نشره من قبل قوات الدعم
السريع حول اقتحام مقر اقامه البرهان واكد
المصدر للعربيه ان الاشتباكات جرت حول
مقري البرهان وحميتي وتم ابعادهما وان
فيديو اقتحام الدعم السريع لمقر البرهان
مضلل وغير حقيقي
ينضموا الينا العميد نبيل عبد الله الناطق
باسم الجيش السوداني سعاده العميد اهلا بك
معنا في هذه النشره بدايه وفي ظل التضارب
في التصريحات والتضارب في البيانات
والمعلومات الوارده من الجانبين نريد منك
تعليق واضح عما يجري وعن مجريات المعركه
على الارض تفضل
اولا السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى
وبركاته نحن نريد ان نحن لا نتحدث الا عن
حقائق وهي حقائق على الارض لانه لا مصلحه
لنا في ان نضلل الشعب السوداني او نظلل
الرايه العام المحلي او الاقليمي او
الدولي حقيقه ما يجري منذ منذ يومين هو
اشتراك
ومحاولات متطرفه ومناوشات بمليشيا الدعم
السريع
للتحرر او للاحتكاك
بالمواقع او المقرات العسكريه في مناطق
متفرقه من الخرطوم نحن حتى الان مفهومنا
لهذه العمليه مكون العسكري بهذه العمليه
هو ان طعم ان نتبع اسلوب هو مزيد ما بين
اسلوب
العمليات اول حرف
الحرب السوريه
اما الداخلي والتي بقرار التقليص بقدر
الامكان
احتفالات اصابات المواطنين وتعريض
هذه العمليه بسياق محدد متفق عليه
متفق عليها سعاده العميد
عفوا سعاده العميد لا نستطيع ان نسمعك
يتقطع الصوت هل مازلت معنا
نعم تفضل
لا نستطيع ان نسمعك سعاده العميد
طيب الو الو ايوه سياده العميد هل تسمعنا
نعم
طبيعه الاحداث التي
تحدث منذ الاول من امس
اشتباكات ومحاولات اقتحامات بعدد من
المقرات العسكريه نحن نتصدى لهذه
المحاولات
واضافه الى ان هنالك عمليات قنص واستهداف
لضباطنا وجنودنا
تم جرت محاولات
لاعتقاد والقبض على
افرادنا ضباطنا وجنودنا الى مواقعهم مواقع
عملهم الرسميه
تم
القبض على اقول اسف اما القبض على العديد
من الضباط الذين هم دارسون في
مثلا قيمه على الاستخبارات او ضباط توجهوا
الى مواقع عملهم في الصباح تم اعتقالهم
واعتبارهم جذوع بشريه في مقرات ميديا
الدعم السريع نحن الان لا نؤكد انه لا صحه
اطلاقا
باستيلاء او سيطره ميليشيا الدعم السريع
المتمرده على اي مقرات القياده العامه ولا
على قصر الضيافه ولا على القطر الجمهوري
هذه التعذيب مضلله الامر الثاني نحن نؤكد
اننا في القوات المسلحه لاننا قوات محترفه
وقوات مسؤوله ونحن نلتزم تماما بجميع
قواعد الاشتباك في مثل هذه الحالات نحن
نتقيد تماما
بمقررات القانون الدولي الانساني قانون
النزاعات المسلحه في هذا النزاع المسلح
وبالتالي
نحن لا نتعرف الى اي اعيان
مدنيه او اي اعيان محميه
ماذا عن الاشتباكات التي تدور بالفعل في
المناطق السكنيه حول المنازل ان ملخص هذه
العمليات منذ اليومين السابقين هي عباره
عن مناوشات حول محيط القياده العامه ومحيط
القطر الجمهوري وبعض المواقف في
الغرفه هذه حقيقه الان انا اتحدث معك
وتجري الاشتباكات والمناوشات ولكن الذي
احب ان اؤكده ان اشتباكات اليوم محدوده
جدا اقل عده بكثير من اليوم
الاول نحن نعصر عملياتنا في هذه المرحله
في التصدي لمحاولاتهم اقتحام بعض المواقع
مكاسب الجيش سياده العميد ما هي حتى الان
كلها تحت سيطره القوات المسلحه مقرات
القوات المسلحه في محيط القياده العامه
لجميع مقرات القياده العامه هي الان تحت
سي
طره
العميد عن وضع في الوضع في مطار مروي
والقاعده هناك تحت سيطرتكم
في مروي مطار مروي والقاعده هناك
صباح اليوم على مطار ملوي
ودخلوا الى مطر مروي هذه حقيقه هذه حقيقه
نعم هل عدتم السيطره على المطار والقاعده
حتى الان حتى الان تجري المحاولات وستتم
السيطره على المطار في وقت لاحق بنهايه
هذا اليوم ان شاء الله ماذا عن الوضع في
مطار الخرطوم
الو ايوه يا سياده العميد هل تسمعنا نحن
معك
العميد نبيل هل تسمعني
طيب يبدو اننا نفقدنا الاتصال
سياده العميد هل مازلت معي
طيب اود ان اوجه لك سؤال اخير سياده
العميد نبيل ان كنت مازلت معنا طيب يبدو
اننا فقدنا الاتصال مع العميد نبيل عبد
الله الناطق باسم الجيش السوداني
كان قد اظهر مقطع فيديو تحليقا مكثفا
لطيران الجيش السوداني في منطقه شرق النيل
بالعاصمه الخرطوم وسط اصوات لتبادل اطلاق
النار وتصاعد الدخان من عده مواقع
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا يوسف عزت المستشار السياسي
لنائب رئيس مجلس السياده وقائد قوات الدعم
السريع اهلا بك معنا سيد يوسف هل لك ان
تنقل الوقائع والحقائق لنا من جانبك
سيد يوسف هل تسمعني
سيد يوسف كنت اسالك عن وقاع وقائع الاحداث
على ارض المعركه لديكم هل لك ان تصف لنا
ما يجري على الارض
طيب يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال معه كذلك
وسنعود حل تمكنا من ذلك بطبيعه الحال وكما
اظهرت صور الاقمار الصناعيه مدى تضرر
المباني الحكوميه في السودان اثرى
الاشتباكات المندلعه من بينها مطار
الخرطوم الدولي والمقر الرئيسي للقوات
المسلحه السودانيه اضافه لاحد المستشفيات
ومبنى وزارتي الدفاع والطاقه وكذلك ايضا
هيئه السكك الحديديه
[موسيقى]
من الخرطوم معنا مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي اهلا بك معنا سالم اذا كنا نتحدث
قبل قليل الى الناطق باسم الجيش السوداني
وكان قال بان جميع مقرات القياده العامه
تحت سيطرتهم انقل الصوره لديك
اهلا بكم
قبل قليل يعني بدات هناك اصوات
لمخيره وكذلك المدافع بدات في
الارتفاع قبل قليل وما زالت حتى هذه
اللحظه الاخيره متقطعه
واقل من امس بكثير في مثل هذا التوقيت
لكن على الارض شوارع تبدو خاليه هي
الخرطوم الى حد ما هناك حركه لكن ليست
الحركه الطبيعيه في مثل هذا التوقيت
المعتاد هنا طيران ايضا يحلق فوق السماء
الخرطوم
وينفذ ضربات جويه على حد
ما لدينا معلومات لكن
لا نعرف حتى الان اين يتم تنفيذ هذه
الطلبات الجويه او في اي مكان
سلم المعذره على المقاطعه ابقى معي قليلا
لانتقل واعود الى يوسف عزت المستشار
السياسي لنائب رئيس مجلس السياده وقائد
قوات الدعم السريع حيث ان الاتصال عاد معه
سيد يوسف اهلا بك مجددا كنت اسالك عن يعني
رؤيتك وصفه ومواصفات او كيف تصف ارض
المعركه لديكم مجريات المعركه على الارض
هناك سيد يوسف
المعركه تبدو في خواتيمها الان سيطره قوات
الدعم السريع على مقر مقر القياده العامه
على مبنى الاستخبارات العسكريه على مبنى
الشرطه العسكريه على مسجد البرهان على كل
المواقع وجاري تنشيط القياده العسكريه
وجاري التحكم السيطره على على مقر السيطره
واداره العمليات داخل القياده التي كان
يزيد منها البرهان العمليات الان البرهان
هاري
الدعم السريع مسيطر على كافه مداخل ومنافذ
الخرطوم واطرافهم درمان ومتواجد في كل
مكان لحسم المعرفه
الا باستلام البرهان شخصيا والالغاء القبض
عليه لانه هو اللي جرى الجيش لهذه المعركه
الخاسره هو اللي ورط البلاد كلها في عمليه
العمليه دعناها عمليه طائشه هو يعتقدها
انه يستطيع الطيران او بامكانياته
الامكانيات الجيش ان يحكم المعركه في
دقائق ولكن تفاجا بان الدعم السريع هو لا
يمكن هزيمتها ولا يمكن يعني ذكرتهم بان
جميع المقاهر تحت قيادتكم وان المعركه على
مشارف الانتهاء ولكن قبل قليل الناطق باسم
الجيش السوداني قال بان جميع المقرات او
مقرات القياده تحت سيطرتهم هم اذا في ظل
هذا التباين في التصريحات هل لديكم اي
تاكيدات بانكم بالفعل تسيطرون على المقر
الاساسيه والحساسه من الخرطوم
نحن لدينا تاكيدات نحن نشرنا صور فيديوهات
من داخل منزل البرهان من داخل مغاره
الاستخبارات العسكريه لدينا تاكيدات وعلى
استعداد الان
نستضيف اي قناه تدخل مغر هذه المغاره التي
تسيطر عليها وتصورها
العربيه الدخول معك سيدي يوسف
نعم نعم نحتاج تامين دخول
فقط بالترتيب لضمان سلامه الطاقم سنرتب
ذلك في الساعات القادمه نحن نسيطر على
القصر الجمهوري نحن نسيطر على كل
الوزارات نحن نسيطر على كافه مداخل ولايه
الخرطوم والكباري كافه الكباري
التي تربط بين الخرطوم والمدن الثلاثه نحن
فقط عبر هذه القناه نضمن المواطنين ان
هنالك دعايه ان الدعم السريع يعتدي على
مواطنين او ينهب ممتلكاتهم هذه دعايه
رخيصه نحن نؤمن المواطنين ويشهد بذلك كل
المواطنين في الشارع نوع من المواطنين نعم
من المغاربه التي نستلمها ولا ندخلها ولا
نعتدي على وثائقها ولا على اوراقها ولا
على هذه ممتلكات للشعب السوداني
من الدعم السريع السيد يوسف في الاحياء
المدنيه وبين المنازل المدنيه وكانهم
يستخدمون المواطنين كدروع بشريه
لا نحن لا نستخدم المواطنين الدروع
البشريه نحن متواجدين في الشوارع الرئيسيه
في الاحياء متواجدين لتامين المواطنين
هنالكم
اسامه عبد الله وتعتبر بامر علي كارت هذه
اسلاميه
تريد ان تجر البلاد لحرب او المواطنين
لحرب تعمل على التعبئه المطاردهم تتحدث عن
طرف نعم هو ليس طرف ثالث هو يعتبر حتى
الساعات الماضيه كان يعتبر البرهان هذه
العمليه التي قضناها الان نيابه عن كل
الشعب السوداني هي عمليه مدبره تم اتخاذ
القرار فيها يوم سته ابريل باجتماع
البرهان مع علي كرسي انه يسانده لاستلام
السلطه والانفراد بها وان هذه المليشيات
وهذه المجموعات تساندهم هذه عمليات مؤثره
نحن نشرنا فيديو لاجتماع لكرتي والبرهان
عسرنا عليه من طرف من شخص يعمل معهم هذه
هذه المعلومات نحن نواجه حرب تصور
بان حرب بين الجيش والدعم السريع ولكن هي
حرب بين مجموعات اسلاميه على راسها
البرهان وعلى راسها على كرسي وعلى راسه
عبد الله نحن نواجه حرب يهودها تنظيم مسله
تنظيم اختطف القرار داخل القوات المسلحه
ويحاول
القوات المسلحه ليفرض واقع جديد وان يعيد
نظام سقطه الشعب السوداني في ثوره ديسمبر
نحن معركتنا ليست معركه غليله ولكن لذيذ
الشعب السوداني ان يفهم ذلك والعالم ان
يفهم ذلك نحن نواجه قوه على الارض نحن
نواجه قوه
اختصفت الجيش وتحاول تسخير الجيش ليس عدو
بالنسبه لنا والجيش نفسه تم توريطه في هذه
العمليه الجيش بريء الان نحن معنا
اللواءات من الجيش ثم انضمامه الان الفرق
في كل الولايات كل الفرق ليست طرفا في في
رئاسات الفرق في في ليله الطرف في هذه
المعركه جميعهم استعدادهم للتسليم تم
تسليم
اعلن انشقاقهم كذلك والانضمام الى الجيش
نعم هذه عمليه هنالك ضباط في الجيش مثلا
الرسمي تم اختطافه
على التصريح بانه انضم للجيش نحن نعلم
ظروفه ملابسات اعتقالي كل هنالك ضباط نعم
هناك ضباط ابدو الرغبه يمشوا احد يقاتل
معنا لانه قاتل بالقوه التي نستند عليها
وهي القوه الحقيقيه للدعم السريع وما زالت
هنالك قوه لم تدخل للمعركه حتى الان نحن
كل المعرفه ماذا تريد الدعم السريع
للوصول لحل سلمي وتهدئه الاوضاع ووقف
اطلاق النار هل هناك امل
اطلاق النار مع من البرهان الان لا يستطيع
على شيء البرهان الان لا يسيطر على الجيش
يساعدونا لان
القوات المسلحه في الشارع هائمه على وجهه
ليست لديها قياده اذا اردت ان اوقف اطلاق
النار لازم تكون هناك قياده للجيش اتعامل
معها الجيش الان بلا قياده البرهان الان
هانم فنحن
سنفرض سيطرتنا كامله على ولايه الخرطوم
وعلى كل ولايات السودان والامر الشعب
السوداني
لم يستطيع الخروج
خارج كل المطارات لن يستطيع الهروب الى
خارج السودان ولن تسمح له بذلك يجب ان
يقبض ويحاكم ولدينا الوثائق والادله
الادله التي تحاكمها بتحالفه مع التنظيم
الاسلامي لاعاده سيطرته على البلاد نحن
لدينا القدره على
ماذا ستفعلون ما هي الخطوه التاليه
بالنسبه لقوات الدعم
نحن نتشاور مع قوه سياسيه ومع كافه
الاطراف على الاتصال بكافه الاطراف
السياسيه الامر سيرد للسلطه السياسيه
لسلطه السياسيه ما زال نائب رئيس مجلس
الزياده هو نائب رئيس مجلس الزياده هو
يمثل سلطه
وسنتشاور مع كافه الاطراف السودانيه
لتشكيل موقف موحد للتعامل مع هذا الامر
للتعامل مع مستقبل السودان نحن نناشد
القوه الدوليه وكافه الاطراف المحتمه اننا
الان على الارض اسيطر
هو يمثل السلطه وما زالت القوات على الارض
تستطيع حمايه البلاد نحن نتعامل مع واقع
موجود لم نفرض واقع جديد طيب ماذا عن
الاتصالات والمحاولات والمناشدات الدوليه
سيد يوسف يعني كان هناك اتصال لوزير
الخارجيه السعودي فيصل بن فرحان مع قياده
الكوما دار في هذا الحديث او في هذا
الاتصال انا ارى نحن نحن نرحب
بكافه الادوار التي يمكن ان العبها
السعوديين والامارات والمجتمع الدولي وكله
ولكن الان نحن في خضام معركه بخدام معركه
لهذه وبعدها ستتعامل مع كافه المبادرات
التي تاتينا بصوره ايجابيه نحن لا تقاتل
لاجل شخصنا نغادر السوداني وكل اصدقائنا
الذين يودون مساعدتنا في هذا الاطار مرحبا
مبادراتهم وليس لدينا اي اعتراض على اي
مبادره نحن فقط فقط نؤكد على اننا لا نجعل
لفرد واقع جديد الواقع الموجود والان هزم
البرهان ونطارده وبعد حزم المعرفه
النهائيه سيقرر الشعب السوداني ماذا يريد
طيب سيد يوسف هل هناك هدنه مرتقبه مره
اخرى يعني الهدنه السابقه هناك انباء
تحدثت عن فشلها وانها طبقت جزئيا هل هناك
هدنه مرتقبه او محادثات عن ذلك
انا اقول لك ان الامر ليس هدنه الامر
سيحصل بشكل نهائي وتدعود الحياه الى
طبيعتها ستعود الحياه الى طبيعتها
وسيتحرك المواطنين بحريه وستفتح الاسواق
وكل شيء هذه معركه نحن الان نتحدث في
خواتيمها نعم انا لا لا قد تكون هنالك
مفاجاته ولكن نحن قادرين على التعامل مع
كل المفاجات نحن التزمنا بالهدنه اللي
طلبها
والتزمنا ووقفنا الاشتباك في كافه الجبهات
ولكن البرهان فاجانا باطلاق بتوجيه
الطائرات
وتلك هدنه لم يلتزم بها والان لن يستطيع
هو التزام باي شيء
الاخير ربما لك يعني تتحدث عن خواتيم
المعركه ولكن المعلومات تشير الى ان قدره
الجيش اكبر بكثير ربما من قدره الدعم
السريع من ناحيه العتاد والاسلحه والعدد
كذلك
اختي نحن
سيطرنا عليها من الجيش 200 دبابه بحاله
جيده وجاري ادخالها للمعركه نحن سيطرنا
على مغار كل الجيش فاقد الاتصال بغيابكم
الان الجيش ليس لديهم رغبه للاستمرار
للمعرفه نحن لا نقول ان اعدادا اكبر من
الجيش ولكن قدرات الجيش لم تستخدم في
المعرفه مره اخرى ونحن قادرين الان فقط
الطيران هو الذي يهاجمنا ونحن قادرين
للتعامل معهم قادرين للتعامل معهم واضح
شكرا جزيلا لك يوسف عزت المستشار السياسي
لنائب رئيس مجلس السياده وقائد قوات الدعم
السريع على هذه المداخله نشير مشاهدينا
الى هذه الصور المباشره والدخان الكثيف
المتصاعد في سماء العاصمه اثراء
الاشتباكات واثره تفجيرات وربما هناك ايضا
اصوات المدفعيات على ما يبدو ولكن سنتحدث
مع مراسلنا سالم الهاشمي لينقل لنا الصوره
بتحديدا ماذا يحدث في الخرطوم سالم
سالم هل انت معي
طيب اذا هذه صور مباشره مشاهدينا
للاشتباكات
واعمده دخان كثيفه جدا تتصاعد في سماء
العاصمه الخرطوم على ما يبدو ان المنطقه
هناك محتده بشكل كبير جدا في الخرطوم ولكن
لنتحدث الى ضيفنا من الخرطوم محي الدين
محمد هو محلل وباحث سياسي في هذا الشان
اهلا بك سيد محيي يعني انت في الخرطوم هل
لك ان تنقل لنا الصوره ماذا يحدث هناك هل
انت قريب من المنطقه التي نشاهدها من
اعمده دخان تتصاعد من اطلاق نار واشتباكات
المنطقه ولكن مفهوم يعني انه يتم يعني حرب
ثروه في محاوله للسيطره على القياده
العامه ولكن يعني واضح من وتيره
المعركه البسيطه بعض الشيء يعني ما نسمع
في اجزاء من الخرطوم لا نسمع الصوت تدلل
على انه يتم التعامل ربما مع الجيوب انا
انا لا اعتقد انه الامر كما يتم تصويره
انه تم استلام القياده العامه القياده
العامه
مجمع كبير فيه يعني
قدره كبيره للجيش على السيطره
وتامينه وبالتالي
يدل القياده العامه لا اعتقد انه هناك
سيطره لقوات الدعم السريعه على القياده
العامه يظهر في فيديوهات قصيره في بعض
المناطق والباحات ثم يعني لا لا نصل
لحقيقه انهم قد استلموا هذه المقارنه
اعتقد انهم اذا استلموا هذه المطار كان
روبرت فيها قاده كبار من الدعم السريع
للتاكيد على انهم يسيطرون على هذه المواقع
تحدثنا مع المتحدث باسم الدعم السريع قبل
قليل او المستشار عندما قال بانهم يعني قد
سيطروا وطلبنا منهم تاكيدات على هذه
السيطره وقد ياكدوا انهم سيسمحون لكاميرا
العربيه بالدخول لهذه المقر وهذه الاماكن
ولكن الى ذلك الحين لا يوجد بالفعل اي
تاكيدات وهناك ما زال تباين وتضارب في
التصريحات والمعلومات سيد محي الدين يعني
في ظل هذا التباين والتضارب في التصريحات
كيف يمكن ان نقيم المشهد وماذا يحدث في
العاصمه تحديدا
انا حسب المعطيات المتوفره
والهجوم اللي جنبي الجيش على مقرات وخطوط
امداد قوات الدعم اعتقد انه الجيش الان له
السيطره الميدانيه بشكل كبير صحيح في بعض
المناطق في الخرطوم توجد فيها قوات الدعم
السريع لانه حسب عدد كبير من قواته في
ولايه الخرطوم بشكل اساسي لكن الجيش
بالصور التي نراها
والفيديوهات تنتشر دباباته في شوارع
الخرطوم هذا يعني انه
يدير معرضته مع
القوات الهائمه من القوات الدعم السريع
وانا هنا على انه فقدوا تقريبا كل المقرات
التي كانوا يرتكون فيها في ولايه الخرطوم
وفي مدينه الخرطوم تحديدا وبالتالي هم
يتحركون في مساحه واسعه
راينا عدد كبير منهم يسلمون انفسهم للقوات
المسلحه المؤشرات ليست في صالح الدعم
السريع على المدى المتوسط والطويل حسب
رؤيته لانه الجيش عنده خطوط امداد يستطيع
انه
يوصل التعزيزات لقواته يتحرك
هذه التي يستخدمها الجيش يعني وحتى كان
تحدث ايضا عن انهم قطعوا خطوط الامداد
للجانب الاخر للدعم السريع ولكن ابقى معي
سيد محي الدين سانتقل او سابقى في الخرطوم
وانتقل الى مراسلنا هناك سالم الهاشمي
لينقل لنا الصوره تحديدا عما يحدث في ارض
المعركه تفضل سالم
التحديثات
هذه التحديثات حتى الان وهي الطيران الذي
يقوم في سماء الخرطوم الان
ايضا
نائب رئيس مجلس السياده
قوات الدعم السريع تحدث على انهم يدعون
المجتمع الدولي للتدخل وقال نحن نحارب
الاسلاميين المعركه التي يخوضها هي ثمن
الديمقراطيه قال هذا الحديث على تغريده
على تويتر
ايضا الان نستمع الى اصوات الرصاص وكذلك
هذه الاصوات وهذه الاشتباك
تجاه القياده العامه للجيش
اذا هذا ما نراه على الشاشه امامنا من
الدخان تتصاعد هي في مقر قياده مقر
القياده العامه
العامه للجيش ام لا طيب
الوضع الانساني في الخرطوم سالم
عمل الوضع
هذه الاوضاع التي يعيشها السودانيون في
هذه الايام هي حقيقه امور انسانيه محتاجه
الى وقف
لاطلاق النار او فتح المطارات الامنه
لوصول المساعدات او وصول المواد الغذائيه
للمواطنين حتى
هذا الامر يحتاج الى
يعني نظرا من الجانبين من الجيش السوداني
ومن قوات الدعم السريع
والمستشفيات هل هي مكتظه هل هناك
ازمه حتى الان ام لا
بالنسبه للمستشفيات هناك بعض المستشفيات
لا تتحمل الطاقه الكافيه لوجود
المرضى في ذلك يعني في في توقيت واحد
وايضا الصليب الاحمر
يقول انه قالقون للغايه بشان سلامه
المدنيين في السودان وان الاشتباكات
المستمره في المناطق المكتظه بالسكان وهذا
يعرض المدنيين للخطر
ودعم الصليب الاحمر جميع الاطراف
الاحترامي التزاماتهم وفقا للقانون الدولي
الانساني
هذا الامر ايضا يحتاج الى
الجانبين من الجيش السوداني مقوات المسلحه
وكذلك الدعم السريع لان هذه المساله
تحتاج الى فتح لهذه الممرات الامنه حتى
الان يوجد عالقين في الخرطوم ما زالوا
متواجدين في الخرطوم ولا يستطيعون الخروج
من اماكن عملهم مثلا كان مثلا موظفين او
غير ذلك لا يستطيعون الخروجهم
في المدارس
هذا الامر يحتاج الى نظر من الجانبين لاجل
فتح الممرات الامنه للخروج العالقين اولا
ولضمان وصول المساعدات وكذلك المواد
الغذائيه ماذا عن الكهرباء سلام الوقود
المواد الغذائيه هل عاده الكهرباء هل هناك
نقص في العقود والمواد الغذائيه
كليا عاده الكهربائيا
لكن ما زالت
يعني موضوع الماء يعني قطاع التيار المائي
حتى هذه اللحظه لا توجد مياه في اكثر
مناطق الخرطوم وهناك مناطق توجد بها مياه
عاده يعني تدريجيا او جزئيا وما زالت
الكثير من البازل لا توجد بها مياه طيب
ابقى معي سالم لننقل هذه الصور المباشره
لما يحدث في الخرطوم من اشتباكات وتبادل
لاطلاق نار واعمل الدخان مستمره ومتصاعده
بشكل كثيف على سماع
الخرطوم على ما يبدو بان الاشتراكات هي
اكثرها حول مقر القياده لنستمع
اذا هذه صور مباشره ننقلها لكم مشاهدينا
من الخرطوم والاشتباكات التي تحدث بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريعه كذلك وباقينا
في الخرطوم ولكن نتحدث الى الصحفيين محمد
شمس الدين ومن القاهره امان الطويل مديره
البرنامج الافريقي بمركز الاهرام للدراسات
السيده اماني ربما ابدا معك كان هناك
احاديث عن زياره
اعضاء من الاتحاد الافريقي ورؤساء الى
الخرطوم للتهدئه ما شان ذلك
يعني الحقيقه احنا بالامس سمعنا عن
مجهودين
متوازيين عن مبادره مصريه جنوب سودانيه
مشتركه
وقيل ايضا واظن على قناتكم انه برعايه من
الامم المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي ثم سمعنا
عن مجهود قام به الاتحاد الافريقي منفردا
من اديس ابابا
بزياره تجمع الى جانب سلفاكير رئيس جنوب
السودان
رئيس كينيا ورئيس جيبوتي
والمشهد بالنسبه لي كده فيه شويه يعني في
نوع من انواع التقاطع في نوع من انواع
التنافس فيما يتعلق بالتعاطي مع الازمه
السودانيه
فالحقيقه ده مضر بالسودان ومضر باهل
السودان
فيبدو انه يعني احنا دخلنا بعد يومين من
الاشتباكات المسلحه في السودان
لحاله من حالات التنفس الاقليمي وده
الحقيقه هيفضي الى ما
احمد عقبه وهنا الاتحاد الافريقي بيتم
استخدامه في ظني من جانب اديسه بابا
باعتبارها دوله المقر طبعا نحن نعلم انه
بسبب الموقع جيوسياسي للسودان تحاول كل من
مصر
واثيوبيا ضمان
اقتراب معين من دوله السودان على خلفيه
ازمه سد النهضه هذا هو المشكل الرئيسي
وربما يكون الدافع الرئيسي لتقاطعات
اقليميه سوف يدفع ثمنها الحقيقه السودان
واستقراره في المرحله المقبله
والاتحاد الافريقي والايجاد اسمحي لي اكمل
الجمله الاتحاد الافريقي والايجاد كانوا
فاعلين في الازمه السودانيه منذ عام 19
حتى 23 ولم تسفر هذه المحاوله عن تقدم
يذكر بل افضت الى هذا الاشتباك الذي نراه
امام اعاده ابقي معي السيده امانيه لاعود
الى الخرطوم
والسيد محمد شمس الدين سيد محمد يعني ربما
استمعت انت لتصريحات المستش ار من جانب
الدعم السريع وانهم يعني على مشارف
الانتهاء من هذه المعركه وانهم يسيطرون
على اغلب المناطق الحيويه في الخرطوم ما
رايك في هذه التصريحات وما ان الصحات ما
رؤيتك لرؤيتك للوضع في السودان
ضيفتك الكريمه دكتور اماني في القاهره
والاستاذ المشاهدين اين مكانه يعني هذا
البيان او هذا التصريح الذي كان قبل قليل
على العربيه
للمستشار السياسي لقائد الدعم السريع يشير
وكان الحرب قد انتهت خاصه مع يعني هدوء
الاوضاع الان في محيط منطقه القياده لكن
ايضا في ذات التوقيت يصل الان فقط بيان من
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه يفيد بان
هناك ما يشبه المسرحيه عبر استهداف بعض
البنايات المحيطه في مقر القياده العامه
تماشيا مع حملات التضليل يعني يقومون
باستهداف هذه المباني ثم التصوير بالقرب
منها الاشاره بان هناك عمليه سيطره على
هذه المواقع وما الى ذلك طبعا الان نحن في
اطار الحرب المعنويه بالدرجه الاولى
والجميع يتسابق الطرفان يتسابقان لكسب هذه
المعركه وهذه هي المعنويه عبر ارسال هذه
الرسائل
عبر التسهيلات بطبيعه الحال التلفزيون
الرسمي خارج التغطيه محيد تماما من الخدمه
الان وكذلك القنوات المحليه الاخرى مصادر
المعلومات هي وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
والانترنت بدرجه الاولى لم تنقطع الخدمه
وهذا كان امرا جيدا ليراقب الجميع تطورات
الموقف اولا باول لكن ايضا هذا الامر
يتسبب في
تضليل المشاهد او المتابع المواطن
السوداني بدرجه الاولى
اذا ما اتضاربت الاخبار وتسابق الطرفان
على استقطاب مواقف الراي العام بصوره عامه
هذا امر لا يستطيع احد ان يؤكده الا فيما
لو ظهرت لقطات فعلا تثبت ما قاله قبل قليل
لهذا
المستشار السياسي لغايه الدعم السريع قبل
قليل مساله القاء القبض على البرهان وما
الى ذلك هذه نعم نعرف بانه هو الان
المطلوب الاول لدى هذه القوات ولكن ايضا
من الطرف الاخر
فان القيادات العسكريه او قيادات الدعم
السريع ايضا هي اهداف مطلوبه
للقوات الجيش حديث المتحدث ايضا قبل قليل
عن ان هناك عناصر اسلاميه تشارك في هذه
المعركه نعم هذا صحيح هناك استعانه ببعض
الميليشيات التي انضمت فور يعني اطلاق
نداء لعوده هذه العناصر طبعا هي عناصر
كانت تشكل كيانات رسميه او شبه رسميه في
فتره حكم النظام السابق نظام الاخوان
المسلمين في هيئه العمليات التابعه لجهاز
الامن والمخابرات حينها كانت بذلك الاسم
وايضا قوات الدفاع الشعبي وكذلك ميليشيات
او كتائب الظل المعروفه بانها يعني
مندمجه في مختلف المؤسسات
وتستجيب للنداء بشكل فوري وقد يعني علمنا
بانضمام كثير من هذه العناصر بشكل مباشر
فور اطلاق هذا النداء وانضمامها وحملها
للسلاح ومشاركتها في هذه العمليات هناك
عناصر مدنيه فعلا تلبس الازياء المدنيه
ويتداولون صورهم بشكل يعني تلقائي في
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي بالمناسبه هذا
امر يمكن رصده لكن
نحن الان في معارك في معارك وفي حرب شوارع
لن نتمكن من تحديد الموقف النهائي والموقف
العام الا اذا تمكن يعني احد الاطراف من
اعلان النتيجه النهائيه عبر بيان عبر
التلفزيون الرسمي على سبيل المثال ومن
داخل
القواته على هيئه الاذاعه والتلفزيون
واعاده البث كذلك ابقى معي السيد محمد
كرما لاعود اليكم بعد قليل فقد اعلنت
نقابه اطباء السودان ارتفاع حصله ضحايا
الاشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
الى 97 قتيلا وعدد كبير من الجرحى وفق
البيان فان عدد القتلى يتجاوز هذه الحصيله
منذ اندلاع الاشتباكات لاسيما وان الكثير
منهم لم ينقلوا الى المستشفيات اما بسبب
وضع حرج او صعوبه في التنقل
وكما نشاهد مشاهدينا هناك اعلان للناطق
باسم الجيش السوداني
لاستعاده البث في
التلفزيون الرسمي للسودان كما نرى امامنا
على الشاشه حيث تمت السيطره والاستيلاء
على قواعد ومقرات ميليشيا الدعم السريع
بحسب بيان الجيش
وهناك سيطره لبورت سودان الدمازين كسلالك
ضارف وكادقلي وكوستي ومعسكر كرري في شمال
ام درمان بكامل عتادها العسكري بحسب بيان
الجيش الذي اعاد السيطره على هيئه الاذاعه
والتلفزيون الرسمي في السودان اعداد كبيره
على ما يبدو من افراد الدعم السريع تسلم
نفسها وعتادها للوحدات العسكريه في
العاصمه الخرطوم والولايات المجاوره كذلك
وهذا بحسب البيان الصادر من قياده القياده
العامه للقوات المسلحه في التلفزيون
الرسمي للسودان وهناك لا صحه لادعاءات
الدعم السريع باستلائها او مجرد اقترابها
من اي من مقرات القياده العامه وقد تعرض
برج القوات البريه للحريق نتيجه لنيران
الاشتباكات الصباحيه ولم يصب احدا باي اذى
بحسب القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه اي
الجيش
حتى المبعوث الامميه للسودان فولتر بيرست
جميع الاطراف على احترام التزاماتها
الدوليه بما في ذلك ضمان حمايه جميع
المدنيين وقال بورت ان الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع لم يلتزم بوقف القتال
لاغراض الانسانيه بالامس الا جزئيا مشيرا
الى خيبه امل شديده جراء تجدد الاشتباكات
وقال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي خلال لقائه
بنظيره البريطاني جيمس كليبرلي قال ان
بلاده تشعر بقلق عميق تجاه استمرار
الاشتباكات في السودان مؤكدا على اهميه
الاتفاق مع الحلفاء على ضروره وقف
الاشتباكات الدائره كما قال بلينكن ان
الشعب السوداني يريد عوده العسكريين
للثكنات ويريدوا كذلك دوله ديمقراطيه وان
محادثات وضع السودان على مسار الانتقال
لحكومه مدنيه كانت واعده ومن جهته دعا
وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس كليفري دعا
منخرطين في القتال في السودان الى اعطاء
الاولويه للسلام
اما وزير الخارجيه الامريكي والبريطاني
فقد دعا بعد اجتماع على هامش قمه مجموعه
السبعه في اليابان دعا الى وقف فوري للعنف
في السودان واضاف بلينكن انه من الضروري
العوده الى المحادثات
ثمه قلق عميق مشترك بشان القتال في
السودان والتهديد الذي يشكله على المدنيين
وعلى السودان وعلى المنطقه نشعر بقلق عميق
تجاه استمرار الاشتباكات في السودان نقشنا
هنا في اليابان الوضع في السودان مع حلفاء
في الشرق الاوسط وافريقيا وهناك اتفاق
مشترك حول ضروره ان يعمل العسكريون على
ضمان حمايه المدنيين وغير المقاتلين وكذلك
مواطنين من دول اخرى لدينا وجهه نظر
مشتركه حول ضروره وقف القتال بالسودان على
الفور وعوده طرفي النزاع الى المحادثات
فالشعب السوداني يريد عوده العسكريين
للذكنات ويريد كذلك دوله ديمقراطيه
المحادثات التي اجيناها كانت واعده لوضع
السودان على مسار الانتقال لحكومه مدنيه
نتعرف الان الى الوضع في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم لكن من الناحيه
الجغرافيه
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم تنقسم الى ثلاث
مدن هي الخرطوم وام درمان والخرطوم بحري
هذه المدن مجتمعه تشكل الخرطوم الكبرى
بعدد سكان يتراوح ما بين 8 الى 10 ملايين
نسمه منهم مقيمون ومنهم متنقلون اليها
يوميا للعمل وكسب الرزق والنسبه الاكبر من
السكان تقطن في مدينه الخرطوم وام درمان
الاشتباكات الجاريه حاليا متداخله في
المدن الثلاث دون وجود خط فاصل بين الجيش
وقوات التدخل السريعه في حال حدوث ما لا
تحمد عقباه واتساع رقعه القتال سيكون امام
قاطني الخرطوم طريق واحد للنزوح وهو
الجنوب تحديدا الى المدن الواقعه على
النيلين الابيض والازرق وفيما يتعلق بسكان
الخرطوم بحري امامهم التحرك شمالا او شرقا
للابتعاد عن مناطق القتال اخيرا سينبغي
على سكان ام درمان انه ددت الاوضاع
الامنيه امنهم النزوح الى المدن الواقعه
غرب وشمال وجنوب ام درمان
نعود الى الخرطوم والصحفي محمد شمس الدين
ومن القاهره امان الطويل مديره البرنامج
الافريقي في مركز الاهرام للدراسات ابدا
بك سيد محمد يعني كنت تتحدث معي عن
محاولات لتضليل المواطنين وتضليل
المشاهدين والمتابعين للمشهد في السودان
ما الغرض من هذا التضليل برايك
يعني النتيجه ستكون يعني عمليه التضليل او
ضياع المتابعين ما بين البيانات التي
يتسابق كل منها على كسب يعني مصداقيه لدى
المواطن السوداني بصفه او باخرى على الرغم
من ان معظم السودانيين لا يعيرون اهتماما
كبيرا
يعني هذه المعركه ولكن يهمهم ايضا ان
يعرفوا مصير مؤسستهم العسكريه وكيف ستدار
يعني على سبيل الافتراض ان تمكنت قوات
الدعم السريعه من السيطره على
مقر القياده العامه من السيطره على الوضع
بشكل عام كيف سيكون شكل المؤسسه العسكريه
وكيف تعد ترتيباتها ومن الذي سيكون في سلم
القياده بطبيعه الحال هناك حاله من حالات
الشقاق ما بين قوات الدعم السريع والشعب
السوداني يعني على عكس مثلا المظهر او
المحاولات التي لتحاول القوه السياسيه ان
تظهرها
الاعلام ولراي العام به صفه عامه هذا من
ناحيه الامر فيما يتعلق بعلاقه الشعب مع
قياده الدعم السريع او الدعم السريع
باكمله شبيه بعلاقه الشعب مع البرهان على
وجه التحديد لكن شعبان ما يكرر ان
الاولويه لبقاء المؤسسه العسكريه ليست
هناك من خلافات مع المؤسسه العسكريه
كمؤسسه
وعناصر ضمن هذه المؤسسه ولكن هناك اشكاليه
مع قياده هذه المؤسسه وهدمها يردده دائما
المراقبون والمواطنون في بياناتهم او في
تعبيرهم عن رايهم عبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي او الفرص التي تتاح لهم عبر
وسائل الاعلام التقليديه الان
الاوضاع ما زالت متفاقمه فيما يتعلق
بالاحوال الانسانيه هناك عمليه يعني
مستمره في قلب العاصمه وفي المدن المحيطه
بها هناك حدود حذر ربما جراء يعني تعب كل
من هذه الاطراف
لاستمرار العمليات القصف المتواصل لثلاثه
ايام الراحه ربما كانت
تتطاول حتى يعني ربع الى نصف ساعه بالكثير
ثم تعود العمليات مره اخرى نحن نتوقف هيئه
اللحظه ان تستمر العمليات بطبيعه الحال
الا ان يحصل تدخل قوي من جهه ما تستطيع او
تتمكن من اقناع الطرفين
من جهه ما سيد محمد اسمح لي ان انقل هذه
النقطه الى القاهره والسيده اماني يعني ما
التدخل القوي الذي يمكن ان يكون مفصلي في
الوضع في السودان
اسمحي لي ان احيي محمد شمس الدين من
الخرطوم الحقيقه يعني اظن لن يكون هناك اي
قدره لاي تدخل مهما كان قويا خلال الساعات
القادمه في الخرطوم نحن نشهد مشهدا ملتبسا
مشهدا ميدانيا ملتبسا وبالتالي من الواضح
ان التواضع العسكري للطرفين على الاقل غير
واضح منا امامنا وان كان استيلاء القوات
المسلحه على مقر التليفزيون الرسمي مؤشر
في اتجاه مصداقيه بياناتهم لكن بشكل عام
لن يسمع لاي صوت مهما كانت قوته قبل ترتيب
التواضع العسكري بين الاطراف والقناه او
ردد دلوقتي تصريحات قويه جدا لوزير
الخارجيه الامريكي لا احد سوف يصغي ولا
اعتقد ان احد يستطيع ان يزور الخرطوم ايضا
في هذه الاونه امامنا ربما يومين او ثلاثه
حتى
يعني هذا الالتباس
ينقشع
ونفهم الوضع الميداني لسنا نحن فقط طبعا
ولكن كل الاطراف الاقليميه الدوليه
وبالتالي كل الاطراف سوف تعيد حساباتها
وتموضعها طبقا للمشهد النهائي لكن في هذه
اللحظه نحن امام مشهد ملتمس طيب اسمحوا لي
ان اشير الى الصور المباشره امامنا واعمده
الدخان التي ما زالت مستمره في التصاعد
وبشكل اكثر مما سبق على ما يبدو هناك
الاشتباكات مستمره الضرب عنيف باطلاق
النار بالمدفعيات واشتباكات حول المقر
الحساسه وحول المدن والمدنيين كذلك انتقل
الى مروي
والمراسل العربيه الزميل نزار بقداوي نزار
من انقل الصوره لنا لديك هل ما زالت
الامور هادئه في مروي ام عاده الاشتباكات
من جديد
التوتر والهدوء
هماما يطوقان ويحاصران هذه المدينه
ويحاصرا ايضا المطار والقاعده الجويه
العسكريه العمليه هنا في مدينه ملوي
استمعنا قبل قليل حسب افادات المتحدث
الرسمي باسم الجيش السوداني العميد نبيل
عبد الله عن الموقف الراهب
طبقا لهذا الموقف فان الهدوء الان هو الذي
يسيطر ترقب للمشهد ما هي طبيعه الساعات
المقبله كيفيه التعامل العسكريه معها
المواطنون هنا ايضا يتابعون عن كسب مالات
هذه العمليه العسكريه الى اين ستمضي
التوتر والقلق هماما
يطوقان ويسودان الاجواء في هذه المنطقه
وفي هذه المدينه من شمال السودان ما زالت
الاشتباكات مستمره حول المطار والقاعده
نزار
حتى الان لا لا صدور لاي اصوات اللي طلقات
لقاذفات لمدفعيه ثقيله او خفيفه داخل مطار
مروي الدولي الان هنالك هدوء تام يهم
المطار يؤم القاعده
[موسيقى]
لا وجود حتى اللحظه لاي اسراب طيران اقلاع
او نزول او هبوط لطائرات عسكريه او طائرات
مقاتله الوضع على ما هو عليه
هنالك تمركز للقوات المسلحه السودانيه في
عدد من الارتكازات داخل مروي وفي الطريق
الذي يربط بين مروي وبين المناطق الشماليه
والجنوبيه لهذه القاعده هذه هي الصوره
الجغرافيه لوجود القوات المسلحه في هذه
المنطقه اذا ربما تحتدم الاشتباكات في
المناطق الاخرى دارفور ربما بورت سودان هل
من انباء وارده من هناك لديك نزار
نعم حرف بالمعلومات والتواصل المستمر مع
المصادر الاخبار والقاده العسكريين
والقاده الميدانيين
وصحفيين من تلك المناطق في دارفور على
سبيل المثال
هنالك حاله هدوء مشوبه بالحذر في مدينه
الفاشر
حاضره ولايه شمال دارفور هذه المدينه يوم
امس كانت فيها اشتباكات وسمع ذوي الرصاص
والمدفعيه مواطنون في الاحياء الغربيه
انتقلوا الى وسط المدينه والى شمال
المدينه الهدوء الان بدا يعود تدريجيا مع
سماع لطلقات في بعض المناطق هي محدوده اما
في جنوب دارفور مباشره في نياله حاله
الاشتباكات مستمره حتى قبل ساعتين القوات
المسلحه تتمركز امام قياده الفرقه في
مدينه نيالا انتشار للقوات المسلحه في
المقر الرئيسه المصارف البنوك التجاريه
المؤسسات الرسميه بعض مقاهر المؤ اطول
منظمات الاقليميه ومحليه تحديدا المنظمات
الغوص والتي تعمل في الانسان تعرضت
لعمليات السلب بحسب شهود عيان الحركه
التجاريه متوقفه الان في سوق مدينه نيالا
وهو السوق الاكبر في اقليم دارفور غرب
السودان هذا هو المشهد الى جانب المشهد
الذي ينقل الان عبر الصوره والصوت من
الخرطوم تحديدا في محيط قياده عام الجيش
السوداني وسط العاصمه
لنتحدث قليلا عن الوضع الانساني نزار يعني
ما هي اوضاع المدنيين والمواطنين في
مرايي في الخرطوم في السودان بشكل عام
يعني هل هناك اي استعدادات للعيد هل هناك
اي استعدادات لختام هذا الشهر الفضيل
الان في السودان بصفه عامه وفي العاصمه
الخرطوم
ارحت العيد بقدر ما هو حديث عن ماساه
اطبقت بكلياتها على
نحو 40 مليون سوداني هؤلاء هم عدد سكان
السودان واكثر كل مشاعر الحزن الان تعوم
او ولايات السودان لماذا تفجرت هذه
الاوضاع بهذه الوضعيه وبهذه الشاكله مع
اقتراب اعياد الفطره المباركه وعيد الفطر
المبارك حاله من الحزن حاله من التوتر
حاله من الخوف حاله من الرعب الممرات
الانسانيه منقطعه مواطنون تقطعت بهما
السبل في عدد من المدن السودان الاوضاع
داخل المستشفيات غير معروفه
ضحايا من المدنيين في مناطق كثيره غير
معروفه معلومات عنهم كل هذه تعقيدات الان
تشوب الموقف في الخرطوم وفي نيالا وفي
الفاشر وفي شمال السودان هذا هو الموقف
وهذا هو الاحساس احساس المواطنين
السودانيين الذين كانوا يتمنون ان تاتي
لحظات العيد بفرح وباقتراب
الانفراجه سياسيه تهيا البلاد لمرحله
جديده بعد عمليات كر وفر سياسي واحتقاء
سياسي وتباعد في المواقف والرها كانوا
يمنون النفسا تنفرط هذه العقد السياسيه
ولكن مضت الامور عكس تيارات التفاؤل
والامل واصبح المشهد على ما هو عليه اطلاق
نار في عدد من المواقع واصبحت الخرطوم
وعدد من مدن السودان ساحه لمواجهات عسكريه
مستمره حتى الان طيب نزار يعني ايضا الى
جانب هذا الوضع الانساني الصعب في الداخل
السوداني ايضا هناك يعني سودانيون عالقون
خارج السودان يعني السعوديه اعلنت استضافه
المعتمرين على نفقاتها والزائرين ولكن ما
شان العالقون خارج السودان في اماكن اخرى
يعني كيف سيعودون الى السودان وعائلاتهم
وبلدهم
هذا هو التحدي الحقيقي يعني بالنسبه
للمعتمرين السودانيين يعني من البشريات
التي اطلقت كان لاول مره ان
تستجيب السلطات السعوديه او السلطات الحج
والعمره لكافه النسب التي تقدم للعمره هذا
فتح الباب امام الاف السودانيين من ان
يزوروا الاراضي المقدسه وان يؤدوا فريضه
او يؤدوا شعيره العمره كان هذا بمثابه
فرحه بالنسبه لهم كثيرون من السودانيين
لاول مره يزورون الاراضي المقدسه ويعتبروا
نسبه لفتح هذه الفرص واضح ونتمنى لهم كل
السلامه للاسف الوقت ينتهي نزار شكرا لك
جزيل الشكر مراسل العربيه نزار بقداوي من
مروي والشكر موصول لمراسلنا في الخرطوم
سالم الهاشمي والصحفي محمد شمس الدين ايضا
من الخرطوم ومن القاهره
اماني الطويل مديره البرنامج الافريقي
بمركز الاهرام للدراسات شكرا جزيلا لكم
جميعا اذا التغطيه هذه مستمره ومع تجدد
الاشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله بين قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني في محيط
مبنى القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه في
العاصمه الخرطوم سمع ذوي انفجارات في معظم
ارجاء الخرطوم
واظهرت مقاطع مصوره لاشتباكات ثقيله بين
قوات الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع داخل احياء
سكنيه في العاصمه الخرطوم
نشير مشاهدينا الى ان الجيش السوداني يدعو
مجددا منسوبي الدعم السريع الى انهاء
انتدابهم والعوده الى القوات المسلحه اذا
الجيش السوداني يدعم مجددا اعضاء ومنسوبيه
دعم السريع الى انهاء انتدابهم والعوده
الى القوات المسلحه وفي هذا الحين يتواصل
الاقتتال في العديد من المدن السودانيه من
بينها بورتسودان وسواكن حيث اظهرت مقاطع
فيديو انتشارا عسكريا مكثفا وسط المدينتين
[تصفيق]
اذا المعارك ما زالت مستمره والاشتباكات
في احتدام وتصاعد مستمر الى جانب اعمده
الدخان كما نرى في الصور امامنا انتهت هذه
الساعه الاخباريه مشاهدينا لكن تغطيتنا
مستمره للتطورات في السودان ومعكم ابراهيم
بدر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات